Rainer event will ich noch mal ganz
herzlich begrüßen der mit uns diese
Live-Bilder jetzt gerade verfolgt wie
schwierig ist die Situation für die
Beamten entlassen sie uns genau auch bei
dieser konkreten Situation bleiben es
ist alles für barrikadiert selbst die
Räumen Panzer kommen da nicht durch es
ist dicht auch vermüllt mit mit Metall
mit Holz und jetzt ist man in der
Situation man geht dort rein in eine
völlig ungewisse Situation man weiß nur
die andere Seite die ist gewaltbereit
wie gehen die Wahrheit noch mehr
Herausforderungen nicht nur diese
Räumungsaktion man hat das gesamte
Umfeld das heißt die Polizei ist auf
vielen Nebenschauplätzen noch unterwegs
sie muss die Objekte schützen die
attackiert werden möglicherweise das
sind
im Presse Häuser das sind
andere öffentliche Einrichtungen die
geschützt werden müssen und die
versammlungslage die gibt es ja nebenbei
auch noch das heißt die Polizei hat auch
die Pflicht die das Versammlungsrecht
durchzusetzen das heißt Versammlungen
auch zu ermöglichen das heißt man darf
ja gegen diese Maßnahmen protestieren
ist also ausgesprochen schwierig und
diese konkrete Situation angeht die man
ja juristisch auch einsortieren muss die
Polizei leistet Amtshilfe für die ihren
Gerichtsvollzieherin und sie hat mit dem
er Einsatzwagen da ein Loch sehr
vorsichtig reingemacht manche haben ja
die erwartet die Polizei soll mit diesem
schweren Gerät dass sie ja hat nun doch
einfach da mal reinfahren und großes
Loch machen nein sie könnte
beispielsweise andere Personen die sich
hinter die sind Barrikaden verbergen
verletzen und das darf nicht passieren
das heißt das hat man unbedingt
verhindern wollen und wir sehen jetzt
genau diesen Einsatz von eben schwererem
Gerät von diesen
schweren Fahrzeugen der Polizei hier
vielleicht können Sie einmal ganz kurz
beschreiben Event mit ihrer
polizeilichen Erfahrung was aktuell
gemacht wird also wir haben gerade
gesehen dass mehrere Bewohner eben
abgeführt worden und jetzt trinkt man
offenbar eben mit diesen Fahrzeugen
tiefer auf das Gelände ein ja jetzt kann
man das auch gefahrlos tun wenn man weiß
was sich dahinter unbedingt was ich
unmittelbar dahinter verbirgt so dass
der Einsatz dieses Gerätes den wir
anderen Einsätzen schon kennen ermöglich
ist wie überhaupt die nicht nur die
Berliner Polizei sondern auch die
Bundespolizei und andere Einheiten die
hier im Einsatz sind solche
Einsatzsituationen seit langer langer
Zeit kennen also auch dass Menschen
beispielsweise sich anketten oder
irgendwie die Arme im Betonröhren
stecken das kennen wir seit den Castor
Transporten und seitdem weiß Polizei
auch mit solchen Situationen umzugehen
es gibt Höhenretter die die Leute von
den Bäumen holen das kennen wir aus dem
Hambacher Forst es wird ein sehr sehr
langer Einsatz heute werden also man
darf sich von diesen Bildern dass sie da
einige ganz ruhig abführen lassen dich
beeindrucken lassen das ist durchaus
auch ein Teil der Szenerie dieser Leute
die dokumentieren wollen wir sind ja
eigentlich ganz friedlich und böse ist
nur die Polizei das ist ein altes
Szenario das immer wieder eine alte ein
narrativ das auch immer wieder diese
Szene begleitet das ist eben auch das
Besondere auch noch mal an diesem
heutigen Tag dass die Polizei ja auch
ganz klares Feindbild ist das ist ganz
klar wir haben die Rufe gehört wir haben
gehört wie Flaschen die Beamten gerufen
werden wie sie beschimpft werden wie
Gewalt angekündigt wird wie rüstet sich
die Polizei abgesehen von der
Gerätschaft die wir hier sehen abgesehen
von der Mannschaft von der Unterstützung
die angefordert ist wie rüstet sich die
Polizei auch mental auf einen so langen
Tag indem man immer wieder persönlich
auch beschimpft wird immer jeder
einzelne Beamte muss fürchten persönlich
angegangen wird wie kann man sich damit
halt darauf vorbereiten das ist eine
wichtige Aufgabe für die Führungskräfte
in der Polizei für die Zugführer für die
Hundertschaftsführer die in den Einsatz
Vorbereitungen mit den Einsatzkräften ja
sprechen das ist auch eine Frage der
Übermittlung von einsatzbefehlen in der
den klar gemacht wird wie die Polizei
und warum sie so einschreitet und da
müssen Kolleginnen und Kollegen schon
eingestellt werden auf diese
Einsatzsituation vor allen Dingen die
die direkt am Objekt sind wissen
natürlich dass sie in Lebensgefahr sind
wenn sie dort einen gesetzt werden denn
diejenigen die sich dort zu Wehr setzen
von denen geht ja gelegentlich eine hohe
tötungsbereitschaft aus das haben wir in
anderen auch gesehen das heißt Sie
müssen so entschlossen wie Sie vorgehen
müssen müssen sie auch behutsam vorgehen
und auf ihre eigene Sicherheit achten
nun ist es ja gerade zu spektakulär und
machte einen auch wütend wie massiv
diese Einsatz durchgeführt werden muss
wie viel Polizeikräfte da aus dem ganzen
Bundesgebiet heute
eingezogen werden müssen um diese
Räumung durchzusetzen wir haben gerade
Höhenretter zusätzlich gesehen also das
ist ein gigantischer Einsatz heute der
verschiedenen Polizeien haben Sie eine
ungefähre Größenordnung was das kostet
was das für eine Rechnung ist naja das
kann man immer sehr schlecht berechnen
weil die Polizistinnen und Polizisten
die da im Einsatz sind Beamte sind und
die werden sozusagen sowieso bezahlt ob
Sie an dieser Stelle oder an anderer
Stelle im Einsatz sind insofern ist das
für die Polizei kann
Kostenmanagement was der was da ins Feld
geführt werden kann aber für uns ist
wichtig mal festzuhalten hier hat sich
über 30 Jahre eine Szene verfestigt
geduldet von der Politik und dass die
natürlich sich in 30 Jahren auf eine
solche Situation vorbereiten können ist
völlig klar und diese 30 Jahre sind
einfach 30 Jahre zu viel man darf
besetzte Gebäude eben nicht dulden nicht
ein Jahr nicht zehn Jahre und schon gar
nicht 30 dann entstehen erst solche
Situationen geduldet von der Politik das
ist ein ganz interessanter Punkt
benennen Sie uns mal ganz klar die
Fehler wer hat da den Fehler gemacht wo
wurde geschlafen das ist eine Situation
vor der wir jetzt heute stehen 2000
ihrer Kolleginnen und Kollegen sind im
Einsatz wer ist es der
Senat wer hat da geschlafen dass ich die
Szene doch hier in der Hauptstadt so
stark machen konnte ja glücklicherweise
werden wir ja nicht seit 30 Jahren von
Rot-Rot-Grün regiert aber von
unterschiedlichen Koalitionen aber eins
ist immer durchgängig gewesen dass es in
der Politik in weiten Teilen der Linken
Politik bei den Grünen bei der
Linkspartei aber auch in Teilen der SPD
eine breite Sympathie für diese Szene
gibt die wirklich unverhohlen geäußert
wird wodurch man natürlich sich auch
legitimiert wird fühlt im so zu agieren
und sofort zu gehen glücklicherweise ist
es so dass Polizei und auch Justiz also
die Gerichtsvollzieherin ganz ruhig und
entschlossen Recht und Gesetz
durchsetzen und nicht an
parteipolitische Erwartungshaltung
gebunden sind ich kann nur hoffen dass
das noch lange so bleibt und dass die
Polizei nicht geführt wird sozusagen von
Linken und Grünen Politikern sondern von
Recht und Gesetz das ist der Rechtsstaat
alles andere wäre Chaos sie haben Groll
mit in diese Studie heute gebracht bei
Bild live das merkt man natürlich
nachdem das über so viele Jahre
Jahrzehnte geduldet wurde wie sehr
spüren Sie diesen Groll auch unter den
Beamten die im Einsatz sind die das
heute natürlich hoch professionell
machen und ganz ganz sachlich und
deeskalierend aber inwieweit merken Sie
diesen Groll in Reihen der Polizei
grundsätzlich spürt man den schon bei
den Kolleginnen und Kollegen wenn man
mit ihnen spricht bei diesem Einsatz
nicht ich bin heute morgen da auch vor
Ort gewesen schon gesehen wie der einige
von schwarz vermummten oft aufmarschiert
sind haben in vielen Einsatzkräften
gesprochen die sind gelassen und
wirklich professionell sie wissen ganz
genau sie haben gefährlichen Auftrag
aber sie haben einen gesetzlichen
Auftrag und fühlen sich auch sicher auf
der Seite von Recht und Gesetz das was
sie machen ist Rechtsstaat durchsetzen
und deshalb haben Sie ein gutes Gefühl
dabei auch wenn sie hochwachsam sind
völlig klar aber eben auch mit der
notwendigen professionellen Gelassenheit
sie haben ja eine gute Schutzausstattung
sie haben gutes Gerät sie haben auch
erfahrene Führungskräfte die die Szene
kennen die sich auch gut vorbereitet
haben von daher im Einsatz gibt es
keinen Groll da gibt es Professionalität
das ist genau richtig und da gibt es
Ruhe und entschlossene Gelassenheit was
ganz Deutschland kümmert gerade noch mal
an den Wappen am armsee Niedersachsen
haben wir gerade gesehen das sind
Berliner Kollegen aus Sachsen haben wir
gesehen hier Berliner Kollegen
die Bundespolizei ist im Einsatz und aus
etlichen anderen Ländern wird Berlin
immer unterstützt bei solchen Einsätzen
das ist ja auch selbstverständlich alle
Länder unterstützen sich gegenseitig und
die Bundespolizei natürlich auch und
alle Länder haben auch unterschiedliche
Erfahrungen wie beispielsweise
höhenrettungskräfte aus
Nordrhein-Westfalen die kennen das aus
dem Hambacher Forst und die werden dann
natürlich auch angefordert und die
können das auch aber der Einsatz da darf
man sich keine Illusionen machen der
wird noch lange viele Stunden heute
dauern das heißt ich denke mal dass bis
in die Abendstunden hinein das dauern
wird und selbst wenn er dann vor Ort
erstmal beendet ist werden die
anschließenden Demonstrationen und
Auseinandersetzung uns noch lange
beschäftigen und das erleben wir ja hier
in der Hauptstadt die ich zum ersten Mal
ihre Prognose wie sehr wird es hier
knallen heute Nacht also insbesondere
nach dem Einsatz wird sich die ganze Wut
gegen die Einsatzkräfte entladen und da
kann man sich durchaus auch auf
gewalttätige Auseinandersetzungen
einrichten die geplante Wut muss man ja
sagen das ist angekündigte Wut das ist
inszenierte das sind Menschen die
pilgern da heute hin was sind das ihre
Erfahrungen nach für Menschen die das
alles noch unterstützen also die
linksextremen das ja jetzt keine so
große Gruppe dass die zu Tausenden auf
die Straße geht aber so haben wir es
beim letzten Mal erlebt rund um Liebe
ich 34 als dann eben so massive
Demonstrationen unterstützt von so
vielen auf den Straßen am Abend in der
Nacht stattfinden also was sind das für
Leute die dann dahin pilgern und ihren
Kolleginnen und Kollegen zusätzlich das
Leben schwer machen es sind eigentlich
nicht viele es sind manchmal die werden
auch durch durch manche Kameraaufnahmen
dann viel mehr zu viel mehr gemacht als
sie in Wahrheit sind ja es sind immer
einige hundert die besonders
gewaltbereit sind und die dann auch
diese massiven Bilder reproduzieren aber
die gerade bei der Liebigstraße hat man
ja gesehen dass die Anwohnerinnen und
Anwohner völlig genervt sind von dieser
Szene das überhaupt nicht wollen das
gilt mit Sicherheit auch für die
Anwohner dieser Szenerie die wollen da
in Ruhe und Frieden leben und nicht
permanent von diesen Einsätzen behelligt
werden und die wollen auch nicht
permanent diese Szene vor Augen haben
die ist in Wahrheit gemessen an der
Berlin aber Bevölkerung sehr klein aber
sehr gewaltbereit und sehr lautstark und
sehr wirkmächtig man sieht ja das
Parteien wie die Grünen und die Linken
in folgen und unverhohlen für sie aus
Sympathie äußern
[Musik]